[Applause]
[Music]
we haven't quite left the first quarter
of the year behind and before we do
there was some heavy-hitters launching
very soon whether you and your gaming
buddies want a sail a ship take down a
giant or escaped prison there's a little
something for everyone this week let's
take a look at some of the biggest games
on the way first off we'll set sail with
sea of thieves if I tell you the game is
about forming a pirate crew with your
friends you can probably figure out the
rest you can explore a massive ocean run
a tight ship battle other crews search
for buried treasure and so much more and
it all comes with that signature
silliness from developer rare after some
high seas delays you and your matey's
can finally band together on Xbox one
and PC on Tuesday March 20th just keep
an eye out for that deadly Kraken maybe
your crew would rather defend your
hometown from giant people-eating freaks
for you there's attack on Titan 2 this
follow-up to the game adaptation of the
smash hit anime and manga series picks
up right after the first and this time
you'll be able to play the whole thing
in coop of course you can always slay
the Giants by yourself using a new
custom character - that's headed to ps4
PS Vita xbox one pc and nintendo switch
on Tuesday to 20th but I'm sure that
awesome theme song is already playing in
your head
[Music]
now let's talk about a way out yet
another game that's all about co-op one
player controls Leo the other controls
Vincent and you both just want to get
out of jail this forced co-op experience
means one of you can interact with the
environment when the other is in a
cutscene or face a sticky situation from
multiple angles you can find your own
way out on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
the 23rd but if you're inching to plan
your escape sooner you can check out our
interview with the excitable game
director himself Joseph Perez right now
speaking of crimes
you can also solve some with detective
Pikachu this week this particular
Pikachu can talk and although he's sadly
not voiced by Danny DeVito he's still
smart enough to team up with Timmy to
solve mysteries around town this
adventure game won't see you choosing a
starter in collecting gym badges instead
you'll investigate crime scenes collect
clues and speak to all sorts of
suspicious characters you can do all of
that on the go when the game comes to
3ds on the 23rd you know what else has
adorable talking creatures ninokuni -
revenant kingdom this RPG sequel puts
you in the shoes of Prince Evan looking
to reclaim his stolen throne hundreds of
years after the first game if you played
the original then you might not be
expecting the game's new Pikmin like
sidekicks the higgledy s which you can
command in combat and you'll definitely
be getting into lots of battles across
the game's open-world after its second
delay ninokuni 2 is locked in for ps4
and PC on Friday the 23rd and those are
some of the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with one more batch of March games
next Sunday